he builds this wonderful base of how he
has a relationship with another human
being outside of all the bs outside of
doing it just uh for posturing yeah this
is just a relationship he has with
somebody and he's also a black guy who's
you know known for being irreverent this
isn't probably the easiest thing to talk
about on stage no but he puts it out
there and he puts his life out there and
then he ends it in i think a really very
fascinating and beautiful way and
especially because he starts it's so
aggressive and that's why it's this
entire piece look so anything in this
piece though taken out of it i feel is
out of context i completely agree with
you when people try to act as though
christians get you know what you get
from christians who by the way they
could tune into any comedy special
particularly catholics right they could
tune into any comedy special here joke
about priests or christians here jokes
about televangelists christians don't
try to get you banned and don't say that
we're going to boycott the world's
biggest multimedia producer i do them in
my act and they laugh right and at the
most you might get if it's really really
offensive you might get this